hey guys and welcome to nerding out the
show where us gamespot nerds and you
talk about the things that we like and
today we're talking about the walking
dead season 7 episode 7 sing me a song
[Music]
lalala oh nice thank you yeah so yaron
much what come on negan guys I need to
talk about negan right now and I want
you all to sum up negan in one sentence
but without using any synonyms for the
word crazy are you ready ah yep go Greg
great likes to sing ease that's two sets
two senses your face no way you're up
Nick terrifying but also lovable Oh
interesting a man who wears a leather
jacket who likes to joke and also likes
beating people's heads end with his
ex-wife bat I like that alkylating man
who you should not cross your summaries
are always the best she's come box
clothes anyway so that's negan and so we
saw negan interacting with Carl last
night so we've been waiting for this
because we've been talking about their
interactions in the comic and how that
went so we got the big Carl negan
episode finally and he took him on a
tour he tormented him there was two
tours yeah a tour of his house now show
me around yours exactly no terrifying
and poor poor Carl had to deal with all
sorts of torment just like showing off
his eye socket which was super gross
that I thought it was really really
gross yeah I was thinking though like
what song did he actually make him sing
uh he just asked him what if what if he
was like what song what song did your
mom make you sing and he was just like
I'm a Barbie you know Barbie were and he
was like what the hell is that like no
superhit songs negan does the the dude
part that would have been an amazing
episode so what do we think of this
relationship like is he grooming him to
be like his new little buddy or is he
doing this to get a trick right so what
do you think dude you know ok this is in
the comics but it's in what comes next
is that what comes after it's from issue
106 they actually have that scene
in there a spoiler just in case boiler
they they have that scene in there were
Leoneans swinging the bat well he makes
them sing so you can kind of tell is
just they're building up the
relationship and we won't know yet what
happens to Rick I don't want to I think
it's interesting though to see like the
Karl negan interaction and how they're
making it grow like there's there's that
like negan throwing the darts and Carl
almost smiles like you see the hint of a
smile now was the first time like he
goes yes and then the camera pans around
and Carl was like I don't smash got sick
Carl's reaction to him doing dumb self
and so like [ __ ] like testing out of
carpet he's playing with a faucet and
the disk cut to Carl and he's like when
when Olivia says she's starving and and
[ __ ] goes hold local are starving and
then turns around and looks back at the
camera like but obviously at Carl with
this like this chick face dude I lost it
like that face i I didn't laugh like the
whole episode was a horrible yeah bad
things happen but for some reason like
that's why this dude is so scary yeah
he's got that dark humor but dark dark
humor so let's talk about knee ghans
wives really quickly so we saw his wives
are all very fancy they've got their
hair done and he even says to Carl he's
like yeah you can look at him no harm no
foul just do it let's do it yeah yeah
let's talk about that whole situation is
that what it's like in the comics his
little harem uh yeah believe so it's
again he's twisted and in every single
way just not just in sexual too with the
way tension between characters and
everything and he every single like he
actually has a line in this recess like
um it was a very hard thing to do but
you know I'm very hard in general
where's like come on yeah okay I get it
we get it you're a horndog and you're
trying to like yeah yes he actually
touched in on that quite a few times in
this episode but I think he's done that
a lot I think the weird thing about the
harem though is that he isn't like a
he's an a rapist and he said that before
you feel horrible feelings when you're
like the chick
that are crying and like all that stuff
because he's not dude he's not raping
but he's coercing you know so everything
in that scene was horrible and he's just
getting in their heads you they they do
these like warnings in the show before
each like after they come back from a
break but we're watching it online you
don't get commercials you just get these
like scenes of like a dude this is
really messed up just so you know this
is messed up so I got like five of those
and I was like by the last one I was
like I agree dude this is a this is this
is screwed up that's that's been one of
them the toughest things for me in these
episodes it's been less about the
violence and it's been more about
watching the relationship between Dwight
and his ex sherry let's talk more about
heinous yeah so we saw a little bit of
that they were talking last night in the
hallway or like in that stairwell yeah
so talk about how he's treating Dwight
and how that might affect things well
you can you can clearly tell that you
know negan considers them even you know
we kind of saw last night with the hot
iron how that works and how you know if
you break a rule this happens to you but
we're even so you gotta think how is
Dwight feeling they're even but he comes
in there last night and they're kissing
and he makes the comments about maybe
I'll have time for one of my wives so
you know what kind of tolls is taking on
Dwight and is he gonna play a major role
you know down the road for the Savior's
is he gonna break the rules or what's it
gonna be like yeah just constantly
messing with Dwight yeah whoo all right
how about Darryl so who gave him the key
I gave him the key in the key so based
on that conversation I think it was
Dwight I think Dwight's like yeah yes
crew this guy dude we gotta i don't i
think it was cherry let me get was
sherry for sure somebody in this
relationship is messing around yeah well
i think the reason why i think it's
sharing is because she still feels bad
about what happened with the motorcycle
you know way back in last season the
reason why i don't think it was sherry
is because in that conversation Dwight
is like we're not doing anything you
know everything's cool and
he's like yeah we're not doing anything
she gets out I think Cherie's scared
like I think that she cares about Daryl
but I think that she's scared and I
think that Dwight just hinted at a
little bit of his fed up penis he's my
fed up a guns and what was on that note
by the way oh I think you look this up
right so oh not that note obviously that
note said go now don't know yeah right
it's not Latin yeah the note that I
don't know the note that i looked up was
Spencer Spencer's fat hunter note tree
tree Tree Walker is what they were
calling it I looked at him he falls down
yeah so gross reddit reddit uh r / Latin
did basically they looked it up and it
was like gibberish with like the word
for water and a couple of Latin words
but then they just like scribbled it in
like they were like that's makeup make
it Latin ish may we'll make a Latin ish
think so it wasn't an easter egg maybe
it was in easter egg and it was just
like I don't know a code or something
but you know give give read it a few
days and they'll figure it out in a few
days and I'm sure they'll figure
something out all right let's talk about
our nerd chill moments of the week let's
start with you Greg which moment give
you chills last night well I brought up
earlier today she 106 I'm gonna go with
just that making him seen while he's
swinging the bed when me and just going
to tell my god that is so cold yeah yeah
that was creepy it's just him sing Hume
are my sunshine barbie girl shine and
hit Barbie will oh yeah creepy Nick
haven't you for me it's gonna be the hot
iron to the face you finally see well I
thought they were going to show it and I
mean they did towards the end when the
skin is peeling off and I think that was
the moment when I was like oh my this
guy could do anything at any moment and
have a smile on his face yeah we smile
about it yeah he always smiles about it
how about you buddy so I think the nerd
chills moment like they both had like
some pretty actual chills moments I had
like a moment where I was like oh that's
gonna be cool the the zombie Lake zombie
Walker pond zombie
yeah yeah yeahs Dombey pond was a cool
moment where I was like that it's gonna
be a cool part of the show that is yeah
just like that visual of the the wide
shot of that whole Lake was really
creepy yeah very like the harry potter
momentum going through that yes yeah I
know yeah my chills moment last night
was negan holding baby Judith at the end
and just talking about murdering her
brother and father while like bouncing
him on bouncing around his knee it's
really creepy I was like oh no no the
baby can hear did she's just looking
into his eyes this is awful this is
awful I hate it I hate it I got you
chills chills chills all around it was
the only one that had like oh that's
cool oh yeah episode yeah all right so
next week we have the mid-season finale
hearts still beating is the name of it
so what kind of predictions do we have
Nick well history tells that we should
have a death because season four was
herschel season five was Beth season six
was Deanna so we're gonna have a death
assuming they keep the trend up but the
big question is who I have a prediction
I'll let anyone go else you know go
first if they have an idea but anyone
else gonna shatter it we know you have
that trunk I know you're a comic book
trump card I think it's gonna be Spencer
spoil alert because of the comics we
know that he has an untimely death
pretty soon with an interaction with
negan something goes along the lines of
you know Spencer wants to get rid of
Rick and we've seen that a lot in the
past couple episodes and Megan says will
you uh you don't have the guts to do it
and while he does that he literally cuts
Spencer's guts out I'm negan style joke
yeah and the punch line is I kill you
yeah but regardless of regardless of the
comics we do see a lot of focus on
Spencer these past couple episodes so
there so I think that everybody's cool
with with with Dwight getting killed so
there is a hope a fan hope for that
annoying dude to get killed because he's
not a scientist um just so you know he
was lying about that uh but uh Rosita
Rosita there is a possibility
rosita could too because of the whole
bullet me a bullet yeah so this is the
only two others that i think are
possibilities it could just be a random
throw away but they haven't they haven't
really just thrown the characters away
at this point yeah no biggie i don't
think anybody it's not no Daryl no Carl
know it nothing too major I wish it
would be Carla please Evie don't reckon
here yeah that's it give him a haircut
it's fine he's just if he's just I
socket buzzed head Carl I would hate
that okay alright so before we go we
also have a correction we made a mistake
last one sorry yes yes so we have a
correction from andrew rojas commented
and said it's oceanside like in the
comics not beachfront there was a
painting in one of the scenes and it
said the name oceanside as well sorry
and you it's not beachfront it's
oceanside yep and we're sorry thanks for
calling us out alright well we want to
know what your predictions are so please
let us know in the comments below who
you think is going to die and the medes
mid-season finale or if you have any
corrections if you have any questions
leave those and we'll bring them up next
week on nerding out and for all things
nerding out stick with gamespot universe
[Music]